the big reason why I wrote this book was
because you know society says that the
person who is sitting alone at the
cafeteria is doing so because he or she
is an introvert that likes their
solitude and that may very well be the
case in many different cases however the
person sitting alone could just be
sitting there because they were
extremely shy and have extreme social
anxiety and they could be a really
social person but their brain their
nervous system just doesn't let them and
really what social anxiety is is
essentially what happens is it
essentially strips your nervous system
from having free will and what I mean is
you know social anxiety is not something
random that can happen to you like the
same way that like you can be born an
introvert people are not usually born
with social anxiety what happens is the
onset of it is around nine ten eleven
and usually what happens is you are put
in some sort of a psychologically
traumatizing event that usually involve
social humiliation that essentially
teaches your brain that you should never
speak up again and like personally for
me you know I ended up going to I ended
up living in a small town by the time I
was nine ten eleven that had five
thousand people and then with no racial
diversity and this was also time of post
9/11 in America and my parents had come
from Egypt Middle Eastern and I was
basically placed to this environment
where nobody around me looked like me at
all and then also you get this bullying
abuse people telling me death threats
all the stuff me seen this as a kid that
basically made my brain fall into this
regression of like everyone hates you
nobody likes you and then every
situation every environment that I was
in my brain was just like Mark look to
the ground don't talk to anybody I'd
never speak up
and you know that was my life for about
ten years and that is extremely
different than just being an introvert
and so I like in a lot of different
places whether it was corporations or
schools or wherever would I go speak I
could almost like immediately see who
had social anxiety because I had lived
it like you can see it in their eyes and
I think the final thing that actually
made me write this book
Brian was when I actually began to do
research and look at the data I actually
found out that social anxiety is the
most common form of anxiety in America
and on top of that out of all the other
anxiety conditions social anxiety is the
most correlated with substance abuse as
well as social isolation both social
isolation and substance abuse are linked
to higher rates of suicide and when I
was looking through my life I was like
wait I literally went through social
anxiety substance abuse social isolation
and even suicide and I'm like wow how
many people out of the 850,000 people
that commit suicide every year are doing
so because they have social anxiety and
they can't talk about it with other
people and then you begin to look at
sort of society's mainstream solutions
for kind of addressing mental health
like you know if someone's mental state
really gets that low then they can call
the suicide hotline a doctor a therapist
and and those are all great but the
reality is is that it's hard enough for
the average person to speak about their
mental health issues it is 10,000 times
harder for someone who has social
anxiety to speak on their mental health
issues and I could have you know I could
have easily see myself you know becoming
a statistic but I'm glad I didn't and
I'm glad I was able to write this book
and just kind of show people like hey
here is my own personal story so that
people can use this as a vehicle for
them for their own understanding but
then also I didn't want to I don't want
to write a book that just kind of like
talked about my story and just kind of
anecdotally
people hey here's what you can do I
really wanted to back it up by science
and to show that there are like these
real verifiable credible ways done
through like peer-reviewed clinical
studies that literally show hey this is
what you do if you have social anxiety
here's what works here's what doesn't
work here's what could work here's
what's probably not gonna work for you
and so yeah that was like the major part
of it like once I saw that like once my
brain like completed all these dots I
was like I literally have to write a
book because I personally don't see a
book that kind of talks about this
picture and how to like go about this
and how to manage it in your own life